[Music]  [Music]  174 members  have recorded their votes in favor of  the resolution  consequently  the resolution for vote of no confidence  against mr imran khan the prime minister  of islamic republic of pakistan has been  passed by a majority of the total  membership of the national assembly  [Music]  37 of the rules  foreign  um  [Music]  is  [Music]  is  [Music]  while imran has lost the battle in the  parliament  he still has a large following in the  field especially among the young and  they are fairly committed so a lot will  depend  how this group under imran fund is going  to  react or interact with the new  government because overnight the new  government will not be able to solve the  problems of the economy the relationship  with the military  [Music]